karine des chaînes call of bonjour merci
d'être avec nous en direct ce matin sur
rtl france alors à maintien du cessez le
feu a été convenu mercredi soir entre la
russie et l'ukraine mais on sent bien
que la tension est toujours présente en
tout cas il ya une sorte de voie
diplomatique qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui que
peut-on attendre de cet entretien entre
emmanuel macron et vladimir poutine
bonjour il me semble que la voie
diplomatique a été ouverte par la russie
il ya quelques temps de cela est que
l'otan et donc les pays de l'otan ainsi
que les états unis ont refermé
réellement la possibilité n'est sortie
diplomatique en tout cas actuel du
conflit lorsqu'ils ont envoyé leurs
réponses demande tout à fait légitime on
voulait par la russie d'une
stabilisation des forces le continent
européen donc la position de maquereau
en ce sens est très classe et une
position qui est atlantiste qui est
totalement alignée qui ne veut pas
trouver réellement un équilibre des
forces entre sur le continent européen
puisque les états unis qui sont quand
même à la tête toute cette histoire ne
sont pas dans une logique de
communication de discussion ils sont
réellement dans une logique de guerre
pourquoi justement les
demandes de moscou sont elles si
difficile à satisfaire quand on voit là
quand on écoute le le discours de
vladimir poutine qui veut juste assurer
sa sécurité
l'otan qui veut pas fermer la porte
justement à certains pays que ça soit le
crès de la géorgie
parce que en fait la russie et l'otan
sont dans deux logique géopolitique
complètement différente la russie vieux
qu'il existe pour les pays un droit à
avoir des intérêts propres que les états
où le droit à leur souveraineté et donc
à protéger leurs intérêts la logique
atlantie surgit globalise dans laquelle
il n'y a qu'un seul le centre qu'ils
puissent décider de ce qui est important
de ce qu'il n'est pas et de comment les
choses doivent être faites est ce
nécessaire entièrement pagny la rue ni
la france ni la chine se sont pour
l'instant uniquement les états unis il y
a donc ciblé une incompatibilité totale
de vision des choses et c'est pour cela
qu'il ne peut pas y avoir en fait sur
les deux ponts premier parce que tout
compromis serait un pas en arrière et ce
exactement d'ailleurs ce que les états
unis dans leur réponse à veulent
contraindre la russie à faire puisque
ils ont refusé le nom élargissement de
l'otan juridiquement ils ont tout à fait
le droit effectivement ils ont raison
dans le sens où chaque pays peut décider
d'entrer ou non dans une alliance mais
la question en débat juridique la
question des politiques aussi proposé un
pacte politique pour stabiliser la
situation pour éviter qu'elle ne se
dégrade les l'otan l'a refusée et en ce
sens il propose à la russie de continuer
le discussion sur d'autres questions
comme la broche la partie mendient
d'ailleurs des questions qui sont
secondaires or si la russie commence à
discuter à revenir à la table des
négociations sur ces questions là ça
veut dire que finalement elle accepte
l'élargissement de l'otan ça veut dire
que finalement tout cette opération qui
a été lancé par la russie pour
stabiliser va la contraindre à accepter
dé facto ce contre quoi elle voulait une
garantie alors les états unis continuent
de brandir à des menaces de sanctions il
m'a sanctionné en personne vladimir
poutine
chose qui n'a jamais été fait sur un
dirigeant c'est que c'est de l'ordre
économique peut-être un gel des avoirs
d'autres menacent également cette fois
ci c'est le gazoduc north stream 2 ce
que finalement les états unis peuvent
mettre à exécution ses menaces
les etats unis peuvent ainsi la russie
ne prend pas une autre ligne stratégique
parce que la ligne diplomatique a
manifestement épuisé ses possibilités
nous le voyons aujourd'hui puisque le
discours se durcit de plus en plus
puisque l'on en arrive comme vous le dit
très justement a envisagé la possibilité
de sanctions contre un chef d'état
légitimement élu et qui a une réelle
popularité à l'intérieur du pays donc on
en arrive à quand même à une situation
absolument anti démocratique et anti
étatique est ce que la russie a intérêt
à continuer sur cette voie je ne pense
pas puisque c'est une voix qui
réellement va finir par conduire à un
conflit puisque c'est une voie qui est
interprété actuellement comme un signe
de faiblesse et non pas ainsi de culture
diplomatique il faut s'adapter au
contexte dans laquelle on vit est
actuellement manifestement la situation
n'est plus à la diplomatie la russie a
intérêt à faire marche arrière toute sur
un toutes ses tentatives de dialogue
bilatéraux avec l'aek les états unis
actuellement de toute façon il reste
l'onu puisque en plus ces états unis ont
demandé la réunion du nord d'un conseil
de sécurité d'urgence justement sur la
question du crâne et là et de la russie
donc de toute manière la russie à des
espaces de discussions de négociations
institutionnelles avec des états unis
elle n'a strictement aucun intérêt à
entrer dans un jeu qui finalement se
retournent contre al puisque les
etats-unis montrent bien qu'ils sont
dans une logique de combat est le combat
ne se mène pas que avec des tanks et
avec des armes et même si ils déploient
quand même des forces militaires de plus
en plus présente en europe aux
frontières de la si en revanche semaine
très concrètement en déstabilisant
l'économie nationale d'un pays et cela
se fait par les sanctions en tuant et en
déstabilisant l'image des dirigeants
cela se fait aussi par les sanctions et
par des mesures de dénigrement et il
faut absolument mettre un terme à cela
pour la stabilité interne du pays merci
beaucoup en tout cas qu'un seul call of
hope d'avoir réagir sur notre antenne ce
matin je vous rappelle que vous êtes
professeur invité à l'université d'état
de moscou